c'est comme un cri du coeur pour ces
lieux fermés depuis la crise du coc
vidal et cafés et bars dans les villes
et les villages
le président de l'association des
commerçants de bourgueil guillaume la
pac a ouvert un lieu dit de convivialité
ce matin dans le village
ils réclament des ouvertures là où les
règles sanitaires peuvent être
respectées lucas chopin
[Musique]
cela ressemble à un bar pourtant
officiellement ça n'en est pas un nous
sommes chez guillaume la pac commerçants
de bourgueil qui a ce matin servi à
boire à qui le souhaitait son but
dénoncer des mesures sanitaires trop
restrictive pour les établissements des
petites villes et l'opération a fait le
bonheur de ses voisins et amis
c'est pour marquer le coup et puis voilà
montre à tout le monde que tout est
possible c'est voilà nous dans nos
campagnes on l'a quand même pas des
établissements énorme qui réunissent
voilà des centaines de personnes on peut
respecter toutes les mesures les mesures
imposées par l'état l'avocat de
guillaume la pac lui s'attend à
d'éventuelles poursuites mais refuse le
terme de bar clandestin
si jamais les autorités venues chercher
noise et bien on s'en expliquerait
devant les tribunaux après tout
c'est un droit absolument fondamental de
pouvoir recevoir ses amis chez soi qu'on
n'est pas les abats on est chez
guillaume qui nous reçoit très
aimablement l'hôte du jour qui assume
cette petite provocation réclament des
mesures adaptées à la démographie de
chaque commune les patrons de bars et
les restaurateurs ils sont totalement
déprimée parce qu'ils ont même pas de
date de réouverture
donc il faut absolument comme l'avait
proposé très intelligemment le sénat que
le couple maire préfet puisse regarder
au cas par cas là où on peut ré ouvrir
parce qu'il n'y a pas trop de monde et
que c'est pas dangereux et là où on peut
pas réouvrir parce que ce serait
dangereux
la préfète d'indre-et-loire interrogé à
ce sujet hier en marge d'une visite
d'entreprise opposent à cette requête
une fin de non recevoir le contexte
sanitaire aujourd'hui il nous amène à
être ultra restrictives sur toutes les
situations qui amène à enlever le masque
alors évidemment on a tous envie de
retourner vers anvers au bistrot on a
tous envie de faire la fête on a tous
envie de retrouver ses proches
il va falloir être patient
malheureusement je serai ravi de pouvoir
répondre favorablement mais c'est pas
pour tout de suite
quoi qu'il en soit guillaume la pac ne
souhaite pas s'arrêter là
il devrait réitérer l'opération d'ici
quelques jours